oui qui sont allés qui ont des rendez
vous avec les écologues je pensais une
fois par semaine ou par mois je sais
plus trop mais depuis la juste après
mars
easy à l'est et puis parce que ça
n'allait pas il se sent très très très
calme très très lisa les cas il n'arrive
pas à supporter les objets qu'on ait
rendez vous via sa fac avec un
psychologue et il va discuter de son
montant
[Musique]
à donges est un ami qui offre l'un d'eux
paye donné qu'il n'a plus sa famille à
cotonou il est venu ici cette année dans
l'optique de rencontrer de nouvelles
personnes décèdent de surmonter leurs
difficultés qu'il a à cotonou vu qu'ils
étaient au feu ne savais plus quoi faire
et ici il est venu cette année il est
arrivé il se retrouve dans vingt dix
mètres carrés je crois il n'a pas de
boulot les économies qu'elle a ramené de
fûts cotonou totalité utilisez vous
payer la facture il a du mal à manger
franchement on s'appelait la dernière
fois il pleurait
[Musique]
personnes nous appellent pour toutes
sortes de raisons en fait maintenant on
en a qui reviennent galles isolement qui
reviennent beaucoup le stress les études
les relations amicales les relations
amoureuses les relations familiales et
maintenant le coc vide aussi acquis et
la pandémie et les mesures associées qui
reviennent assez fréquemment que ce soit
chez les étudiants ou chez les personnes
qui nous appellent déjà avant le
confinement pour vous donner une idée il
ya des études qui montrent qu'ils
avaient une plus de 20% des étudiants
qui pensent au suicide chaque année donc
maintenant je vous laisse imaginer avec
la pandémie en plus donc oui on reçoit
des appels suicidaire on a chaque soir
[Musique]
on
[Rires]
et ces étudiants qui ont tout investi
qui pensaient que il arrivait dans un
dieu où il rencontrerait et possibilités
comme ça illimité d'accès aux savoirs de
rencontres avec les autres d'ouverture
arrivé dans un lieu où ils sont confinés
son col des cours uniquement par visio
impossible de rencontrer les autres
[Musique]
et puis surtout et ça c'est très
récemment
des angoisses extrêmes liés au futur
[Musique]
[Rires]
il ya tous les signes évidemment très
très habituelle qu'ils sont
difficultés du sommeil les mal être des
cauchemars la difficulté à manger
l'isolément relationnel le
désinvestissement dans des objets
d'étude dans les objets d'intérêt passés
et puis les obsessions des idées noires
les pensées suicidaires quand un certain
nombre d'étudiants donc évidemment tout
ça ce sont des six mode alerte important
mais parfois enfin ce qui est c'est
qu'il faut pas attendre d'avoir aussi
est lentement d'aller si loin avant de
consulter parce que venir consulter
c'est déjà un premier pas à faire
étudiant en font un enjeu majeur c'était
le moment où il fallait attendre le plus
longtemps pour nous supporter le plus
possible de venir consulter et non
parfois venir un peu avant que ce soit
trop grave c'est quand même beaucoup
beaucoup mieux
[Musique]